So we should think about the hypothalamus forget,
because it seems to be pretty damn important.
Consult,
I would say,
you know,
people have wondered sometimes when they've asked me,
where's the Super Ego and the ego and the Ed located in the brain.
And you know,
it's a stupid question and it's not a stupid question.
At the same time,
um,
it's actually a useful question at one level of analysis because you could say,
well,
the end from the [inaudible] perspective is sort of the,
the natural force that propels motivation.
You know,
and,
and it's,
when we say motivation,
we're not saying much different than saying in,
by the way,
you know,
it's the same kind of low resolution work.
And it's clearly the case that we have fundamental motivational systems and that
we do share them with animals and that they do drive our behavior.
But they also drive our perceptions in all the ways that Freud thought about,
you know,
and one of the things I really like about the psychoanalysts is that they,
they,
they never make the mistake of assuming that a motivational system or an
emotional system is a mechanical system that reacts to deterministically.
They say no,
those things are like personalities.
And that's,
that's much more sophisticated viewpoint than the typical behaviorist or the
typical cognitive psychologist,
you know,
because they tend to think of the computer in either stimulus response terms.
So it's basically deterministic chains or as if the,
the,
the information processing system is a computational apparatus,
which it is.
But it's not only that,
you know,
it's an embodied computational apparatus and the body is a very sophisticated
thing.
You know,
it's,
it's been very difficult for us to build embodied robots.
And it's also the case that until you build in body robots,
the things don't really get smart,
you know?
Yeah.
You have to have a body for the thing to actually have any intelligence.
And that was actually figured out by a robotics engineer named Rodney Brooks
back in the 1990s 92 93 published a couple of papers on that saying,
you know,
that if we were going to build artificial intelligence,
we shouldn't start from the top down.
We shouldn't build a world modeling machine.
And then embedded in something that moves around,
we should build something that sort of moves around semi autonomously,
like a stupid insect.
Insects aren't stupid.
So I do mean as stupid insect and if we could manage that,
we'd really be doing something,
you know,
and I think we've,
we might've gotten beyond the stupid insect level of,
of robots so far.
Um,
and you know,
it's starting to ramp up really fast,
but it's in large part because the things are embodied.
And so because it is the case as,
as we've discussed,
that your,
your perceptual,
your cognitive perceptual motor systems have to be embedded in an output system
that can interact with the world in order for them to be doing anything that's
actual or real.